indicate to you that there are many
members uh
that represent the people of takoma park
i've been in regular contact with
mayor stewart with the county executive
the chief and i have spoken countless
times over the last several days
and this has been almost uh around the
clock kind of effort by
both my office and and his department
since this event took place
uh david uh paul dixon
who is from takoma park uh has been
charged with five criminal
charges uh since we've almost
be on my way here to this meeting i was
informed that he had appeared
before a commissioner and
he was charged with five matters some of
those matters carry very very
heavy heavy penalties of 40 years in
prison both of the murder charges carry
40 years
uh the attempted murder carries 40 years
in prison
use of a handgun carries uh 20 years in
prison and reckless endangerment is a
five-year misdemeanor
i would indicate to you that when he
went before the commissioner today
as a matter of protocol the commissioner
was not authorized
to release him based on the nature of
the charges
that came before the commission the
commissioner held
the defendant without bond he'll be held
at a detention facility here in
montgomery county
the next time that mr nixon will take a
step in this process
he will be brought before a district
court judge
i don't know the name of the judge it's
uh assigned by the administrative judge
of the court
they'll hold the bomb on monday
afternoon at one o'clock
in the district in rockville at that
time
there will be an analysis of whether or
not that
mr dickson should be remaining rated a
pending
the resolution of this matter or would
be free on bond that is a determination
of a judge that will take place on
monday
i will tell you that uh at the hearing
that takes place on monday
a preliminary hearing date will be set
what does that mean uh
approximately 30 days after monday the
judge will say
by order that the state's attorney's
office has to take action
in this matter indicting this matter
typically what that means
is this matter would be taken before the
grand jury from montgomery county
when we would be asking them to consider
all the facts and circumstances of the
case
the same ones that were contained in the
application of statement for charges
in this case uh i i was told by the
chief you are going to be given
a copy today before you leave of the
application we could not give it to you
until it officially had been filed with
the court it has been filed with the
court
because the bond hearing is over and so
you will see the document
that the commissioner acted on when they
issued the five charges against the
defendant
uh i i would anticipate that
that uh we would move on these matters
as you there are many of you that i've
seen before these matters and you know
that
when a preliminary hearing is set
approximately 30 days from monday
we almost always act and go before the
grand jury prior to that date
and so on the preliminary hearing date
which is 30 days from monday
we would most of the times typically go
in and announce
what we have done or what action the
grand jury has taken in this matter
i am going to confine myself to uh
to the procedures that i've outlined you
have the charging document which is a
matter of public record
uh the chief may be wanting to answer
some ask some
answer some brief questions for you but
ethically
all of you know that i can't make
comments about a pending criminal matter
uh i will say to you that we from the
state's attorney's office would like to
send our condolences to the families of
mr
johnson and mr williams who are the
victims in these cases
and uh i want to i want to just simply
thank
the men and women of the tacoma park
police department particularly the chief
uh who've worked with us diligently
literally round the clock
since this happened and uh
this is the only department only small
department that does the investigation
of their own homicides
and i've been around long enough to know
that this department does wonderful
wonderful work
and they didn't they did a another
wonderful job in this case
and i want to congratulate them for that
standing behind me we have uh the
detectives that worked tirelessly over
the last 54 hours
and we're going to open up the questions
i'm going to bring up detective earl
who is one of the lead detectives in the
case to answer a question specifically
about the case
if the questions are outside the scope
of the case um i may answer the question
so brad if you want to go with your
first question
um
uh yeah the charges that were levied
were the charges we thought were
appropriate like i say it's still an
active investigation
those charges can be amended but we
thought those were the most appropriate
charges at this point
all right
the charging document states there were
inconsistencies in the overview mr dixon
provided
and what we determined in our
investigation and that's all i'm at
liberty to say at this point
uh he was uh off he was uh
not in uniform and i believe he was on
his way to work
did he identify himself somehow
that's still part of our investigation
uh we have confirmed that that the uh
the victims involved
and the other individual involved were
actually breaking interviews
um he first of all that the case does
not involve his position as a law
enforcement officer
he was a civilian who acted as a
civilian who happened to be a law
enforcement officer
in another jurisdiction that being said
we do not believe that mr dixon had any
law enforcement
powers in the state of maryland but as i
said it is not
related to his employment with the
pentagon police
he was acting as a citizen in the state
of maryland um
as we investigated
is there a message from this page that
should go out to everyone
both
that's a very good question um we
absolutely
encourage people not to take action if
they observe criminal activity
be a good witness call us but do not
take action
as i said mr dixon was acting as a
citizen
when he approached these individuals so
we want our citizens to be our eyes and
ears but to call us
to be good witnesses not intercede
themselves i would
highly encourage any of our residents
that encounter criminal activity
to call us and allow us to handle the
were situation brought to dickson in any
way specifically
that's still an active part of our
investigation
the body
williams and johnson were both shot in
the
rear upper torso the back area
that's still under investigation but
that's everything that appears to be yes
sir
uh we're still that's still part of the
investigation it's still active
and we're still looking into uh
comparing everything
my
the video is clear enough for us to see
what was happening
i'm sorry ma'am
no that's still under investigation with
the the vehicle that they were operating
we're still getting into it was
recovered out of that vehicle
again we're 50 some hours into this
investigation
our whole team has been working since it
we got notified
you know very little sleep and
everything is still the movement
fluently
we're gonna we're gonna take about one
or two maybe three more questions and
then we gotta go back and start working
on this again
uh i believe you say you said you made a
statement uh as the charging document
said the statements he made to us
were not consistent to the evidence from
the scene
and other information we obtained
again it's a fluid investigation um
right now i can't answer those questions
no sir uh we uh we have no intention of
charging the survivor of
this incident with a crime um you know
they were victims all three were victims
in this particular case and we have no
intention of charging them
i'm going to take two more questions and
then we got to go back in brad yeah
uh we responded to an incident last
spring i do not have the particulars of
that incident right now
if you follow up with me i i can
ascertain exactly what the circumstances
i'll take one more question
uh mr dixon uh is currently uh on
administrative leave i believe
so you have to refer all questions
regarding his uh his employment with
them
to them so i at this point we're gonna
wrap up
the press conference i really appreciate
you all coming out as i said this has
been a rapid and fluent investigation
and we appreciate the support of the
media and appreciate the support of our
community
and we thank you all for coming out
foreign